Speaker 1: Well, one historic day in American
history.
Yesterday, the January 6th committee of the
House of Representatives investigating the
Trump riots of 2021 has approved criminal
referrals for a former president.
No, it's not against Barack Obama.
Oh, come on, guys.
It's against failed former president Donald
Trump.
NBC News reports January six Committee Approves
Criminal Referrals Against Trump for his role
in trying to overturn the 2020 election.
The panel also issued a criminal referral
to the DOJ for a conservative attorney, John
Eastman.
He's the genius who came up with the strategy.
I don't even know what to call it.
The idea for how former Vice President Mike
Pence could prevent the certification of the
2020 election.
We are going to now hear from one of the members
of the committee, Jamie Raskin.
Let's listen.
Speaker 2: The first criminal statute we invoke
for referral, therefore, is Title 18, Section
1512 C, which makes it unlawful for anyone
to corruptly obstruct, influence or impede
any official proceeding of the United States
government.
We believe that the evidence described by
my colleagues today and assembled throughout
our hearings warrants a criminal referral
of former President Donald J. Trump, John
Eastman and others for violations of this
statute.
Wow.
While the whole purpose and obvious effect
of Trump's scheme were to obstruct, influence
and impede this official proceeding.
The central moment for the lawful transfer
of power in the United States.
Second.
We believe that there is more than sufficient
evidence to refer former President Donald
J. Trump, John Eastman and others for violating
Title 18, Section 371.
This statute makes it a crime to conspire
to defraud the United States.
In other words, to make an agreement to impair,
obstruct or defeat the lawful functions of
the United States government by deceitful
or dishonest means.
Former President Trump did not engage in a
plan to defraud the United States acting alone.
He entered into agreements formal and informal,
with several other individuals who assisted
him with his criminal objectives.
Speaker 1: Also.
Speaker 2: Our report describes in detail
the actions of numerous coconspirators who
agreed with and participated in Trump's plan
to impair, obstruct and defeat the certification
of President Biden's electoral victory.
That said, the subcommittee does not attempts
to determine all of the potential participants
in this conspiracy, as our understanding of
the role of many individuals may be incomplete
even today because they refuse to answer our
questions.
We trust that the Department of Justice will
be able to form a far more complete picture
through its own investigation.
Third, we make a referral based on Title 18,
Section 1001, which makes it unlawful to knowingly
and willfully make materially false statements
to the federal government.
And that is for.
Speaker 1: Just in the interest of time.
This was a very long hearing.
Fourth is inciting, assisting or aiding comforting
an insurrection.
So four different criminal referrals.
How did Trump react?
You could probably guess, but we're going
to look at that a little later.
But let me address some of the emails that
I've received about this.
This is a long overdue step, but that's all
it is.
It is one small step.
And there's a lot of doubt and cynicism in
the emails that I've been receiving from many
of you over the last 24 hours.
And I get it.
I do get it.
We all want to see justice served against
these individuals.
But it is a process and it's worth remembering
that the DOJ has to build the case.
There is an astounding amount of evidence.
They have to piece that case together.
And we all know colloquially and folks, everyone
is innocent until proven guilty in a court
of law.
This show is not a court of law.
This is a place where we just speak frankly.
We all know, as we read through the different
statutes that Jamie Raskin described there,
we all know Trump did the stuff he's accused
of.
We all know that colloquially speaking, he
did it.
But the question starts to become, is there
the possibility of finding guilt beyond a
reasonable doubt here?
We all know and we watched enough to know
that colloquially speaking, of course, Donald
Trump did the things for which he is being
referred.
And this includes all four of those items
that Jamie Raskin mentioned he was able to
incite.
A mob stormed the Capitol on January six,
an attempt to disrupt the peaceful transition
of power and put the lives of members of Congress
and his own vice president at risk.
All of it.
There are some who will argue that the criminal
referrals that we are seeing here are strictly
a political move.
These aren't really law enforcement elements.
This is just Democrats playing politics.
And it may end up being that if it doesn't
go any further.
But this is a necessary step.
In other words, the committee did what it
had to do and it determined we have the evidence
for a criminal referral.
It may stop there, but that's all that the
House committee can actually do.
Now, it is a question of what is Merrick Garland
willing to do?
As we spoke about yesterday and we talked
about the one word that is the reason why
presidents have not been indicted in the United
States.
That word is tradition.
And that's not a very strong reason not to
indict a president who did things no other
president has done.
How could federal criminal charges affect
Trump's 2024 presidential run?
Becomes another political question as we wait
for answers to the legal questions in general.
In like a normal world.
Criminal charges against an individual while
they're running for president would affect
their reputation.
It would affect their credibility.
It would make it more difficult for them to
actually win.
But we've already experienced with Donald
Trump in 2016 that seemingly nothing can actually
damage him.
Enough with the Republican base to torpedo
his presidential campaign.
2024.
It could be different if Trump were to be
convicted of a crime.
Now we're facing many we're taking many hypothetical
steps into the future.
He could face prison time.
Yeah, that would make it difficult to hold
office.
That would make it difficult to campaign even
if he was not convicted or imprisoned.
The fact that he would face criminal charges
could be a liability in a presidential campaign.
To the extent that it becomes a distraction,
it could raise questions about his judgment
or fitness for office.
In a normal world.
But this is the Republican electorate.
This is the very same Republican electorate
who chose him in 2016 and who gleefully welcomed
him back in 2020 as their nominee.
So any assumption that even criminal charges
or a conviction would torpedo Trump's campaign
are possible, but potentially premature until
we actually see what happens.
Let's now talk about Donald Trump's reaction
to this.